[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
welcome walter in our new set yes
i think this is a conspiracy theory
they've conspired to keep us locked in
locked in yes i see they've they've
restricted your arm movement yeah
i cannot move back i cannot move to the
side
i think there is a conspiracy going here
[Laughter]
yeah well let's see how it goes in this
new set we've
well how many episodes we've had 50
right yes
so this is number 51. so
somebody decided that our movements were
too erratic
and therefore they designed this
new set and and maybe this is a the
beginning of
new things let's see i think we are
heading
for very challenging interesting times
and i think martin that
the earth is ripe for the harvest
amen let's open with a word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you so much
for all the blessings that you give us
lord we need you more than ever we need
you every day and every hour
and we need you in this discussion
please open our minds and bless the
viewers and to us
in jesus name amen amen
so today we're going to talk about
souls of men and all kinds of stuff
but we just want to give a little bit of
a back flash
and see what's happening in the world
yes there's some
articles that came out that linking onto
some of the episodes that we've had
yes we spoke about the coming
persecution and
how they are linking the conspiracies of
q anon
to adventism yes and the millerite
movement and the last one so we just
want to
add one or two interesting points to
make that picture complete yes sir
martin there was an
article in snopes
it was a copy of a previous article
and it is by paul bretteman
honorary research fellow and professor
emeritus in chemistry
university of glasgow
and this is what it's all
about and maybe i can just also add
snopes is usually a fact check
website so everybody if there's a
something
that's out in the news and it seems a
little bit odd
odd then they are the fact checkers so
they
are respected as the ones who
will separate error from
reality right so they do put a
disclaimer on
in the beginning of the article that
this is not necessarily their view
but it's interesting that they want to
post this type of article
so obviously they want to put the debate
out there right
that's just interesting so the article
asks why creationism bears all the
hallmarks of a conspiracy theory
many people around the world looked on
aghast as they witnessed the harm done
by conspiracy theories such as
q anon so there we have that again right
and the myth of the stolen u.s election
that led to the attack on the u.s
capitol building
on january 6. yet while these ideas will
no doubt
fade in time there is arguably a much
more enduring conspiracy theory
that also pervades america in the form
of
young earth creationism
and it's one that we cannot ignore
because it is dangerously
opposed to science
martin
science and scripture at loggerheads
there's a statement which says
science correctly understood
will be in harmony with scripture yes
but these days it seems
science correctly understood
will be in at loggerheads
with scripture right
and then he laments the fact that in the
u.s 40 percent of adults agree with the
young earth creationists
that should not be no no that should not
be such beliefs derive from the doctrine
of biblical infallibility
long accepted as integral to the faith
of
numerous evangelical and baptist
churches throughout the world
including the free church of scotland
now this man comes from glasgow so
that's why he mentions them in
particular
but i would argue that the present-day
creationist movement
is a fully fledged conspiracy theory
it meets all the criteria offering a
complete
parallel universe with its own
organizations and rules of evidence and
claims that the scientific establishment
promoting evolution is an arrogant and
morally corrupt elite
martin this man is a chemist right
if he had studied the origin of
the chemical world then
perhaps he would have more questions
than answers
now i was a zoologist and a physiologist
i was also in medical bioscience
and i as everybody knows i was an
evolutionist
most of my life militant evolutionist
until i was confronted with the facts
of this parallel universe
as he claims
and to my great shock
i had to come to the conclusion
that the biblical paradigm and the
biblical narrative
is absolutely in harmony with what we
see in nature and that the explanations
that the scientific world
has placed on the table are nothing
other than conjectures which
cannot and i reiterate which
cannot explain the features
of the geological world
let alone the genetic or molecular world
and therefore this individual
having only been on one side of the
fence
has absolutely zero concept
of what the other side looks like
now did i
lightly change my views
was i struck by a lightning bolt on a
particular day
yes i'm sure no did i have
no a zillion questions probably
yes uh do you think that i would
accept this totally new paradigm without
satisfactory answers
to those zillion questions
no i was privileged i went to many of
the sites
all over the world i traveled many
continents looked at
many many uh
phenomena many features in the world
and came to the conclusion that the
biblical paradigm is the only
one that explains the criteria
and the phenomena as we see them in the
world
so this is a typical statement
from a paradigm of
one-sidedness having never
studied the other side in detail
this is a an arrogance
which is beyond comprehension
conspiracy theories are always driven by
some
underlying concern or agenda
the theory that obama's birth
certificate was a forgery or that the
2020 u.s election was stolen
about political legitimacy and will fade
as the politicians promoting them
fade from memory so he's drawing
connections with
creationism and bringing it into the
realm of conspiracy theories
and with the and if you can remember
the other articles it's also bringing
the q anon and all of that to something
biblical
that was the millerite movement correct
and they always link it
to the millerite movement now let's just
read this one then we'll discuss that
further
i fear that the creationist conspiracy
theory will not be short-lived
it is driven by a deep-seated power
struggle within religious communities
between modernists and literalists
between those who regard scripture as
coming to us through human authors
however inspired and those who regarded
as a perfect supernatural revelation
and that is a struggle that will be with
us for a long time to come
unless of course as we see in the world
today
there are movements to address this kind
of thinking
and to eradicate it from society
get a re-education we might be have we
might have to send people
like us to re-education camps
and hopefully when we're done those
running the re-education
camps will be re-educated
yes that's a good do you think it's
possible i hope so
it happened to paul yes he was sent to a
re-education camp in the entire prison
baptized yes so let's see if we can have
similar experiences we don't
know but another point martin
previously they linked the q and on
conspiracies to the millerite movement
and the failed so-called failed
prophecies
regarding the 2300 day prophecy correct
and we discussed that in detail in one
of the previous whatsapps
but here creationism is brought
to the fore yeah and creationism
is rooted in the first week
of time yes in the book of genesis
right yes and what was the culmination
of that week the seventh day sabbath
the seventh day sabbath
and on the seventh day god
rested from all his work isn't that what
it says
he put his autograph not his signature
that's right he on the week on creation
he put his autograph
on creation and he said this is mine
and there are certain rules and
regulations
which will govern this new phenomenon
and he set the sabbath as a memorial
to that creation so can you see that
this creation conspiracy theory
links directly to the sabbath
absolutely just something interesting
aside if god is in this
and he wants to make the difference
between the two paradigms
prominent as is happening in the world
do today think god will provide
incidences or events
of such a nature that people will be
confronted with the seventh-day sabbath
issue definitely
you think so yeah i found it fascinating
to read i'm totally cutter
i can't swing back and i can't swing to
the side never know
people won't get seasick so they weren't
saying that they were getting seasick
i find it totally fascinating
that the lead lawyer in the trump
impeachment is a
very staunch jew and has made it quite
plain that he will not be available
on the sabbath day which the church of
course
calls the jewish seventh day
totally incorrectly because it was
instituted in eden
that he won't be available from friday
sunset until
the sabbath is over and the whole
committee
must obey because he's not available
you think some might be irritated by
that yes
could it become a prominent issue yes
i find these little nuances so
interesting it is it is very interesting
it's like everywhere god is putting some
things in there
just look here just look here yeah now
we're not going to give a lecture on
creation evolution
you can put a link into the lectures on
evolution creation
i will and then people can look at those
genesis conflict and there's a book
that's written and there are many other
books written as well
this is not a debate of fools no
and there's also a book by the name of
in six days why 50
scientists with phds from secular
universities believe in creation
and uh i'll put the link for that book
put the link in and let's see
that people you know can have an
opportunity
to see both sides of the story now i
must admit
that when i was an evolutionist
i would probably have written just like
this professor
yeah of chemistry wrote here or like
dawkins rights
right and
i don't know have you ever read the book
the god delusion
no right it's one of the most
derogatory books when it comes to the
bible
and religion that has probably never
been written
i think dawkins took the
took the dictionary and chose every
negative
adjective that he could find and
applied it to to god
but if you read the book and i of course
have read many of his books
then you come to the conclusion that his
understanding of the issue
is totally flawed because he doesn't
regard
the god of the bible at all
he takes into account only roman
catholic teaching about the bible
which is absolutely the antithesis of
what the bible stands for
so these scientists
are perhaps scientifically well schooled
but religiously dwarfed
let's leave it at that
here's an article from fox news from the
8th of february
that's not too long ago is it no
liberal media pushes q anon as
the new bogeyman post-trump face of the
republican party
as the mainstream media struggles to
find a new identity without
president trump to criticize at every
turn
critics have noticed many liberal news
organizations have attempted to make the
q anon conspiracy theory its latest
foil in the post-trump world
cnn is not alone in its endless q anon
coverage
as much of the liberal media is
infatuated with the
unhinged theory it's interesting now
this is a conservative
news and they are also
using very negative terminology when it
comes
to q anon and all of these things now
can we just make a disclaimer here some
people think
that we have chosen sides yeah
in terms of trump or in terms of
biden administrations nothing could be
further from the truth
exactly i assure the listeners
we have not chosen side we
see the whole game as a hegelian
dialectic
if you go back and watch the
episodes from episode one of what's up
you'll realize that
because we continually were showing
the trump side yes and now we're
showing the blind side so there is no
choosing of sides here
we are not influenced hopefully
by any of the policies there are of
course things which we observe
that are very strange but there were
very strange things on both sides
right and our perspective
is purely how does
everything fit into the biblical
picture picture how does it fit in there
so we're not taking any side but it is
obvious that all sides are condemning q
anon
yes now that doesn't mean that i'm
fought to q anon
no we've showed that as well absolutely
not
it is a tool that that's so important to
create a mindset
and if you are linking the events the
biblical event
events of the 2300 day prophecy the
mullerite movement
seventh day adventist to queue and on
and now you are linking
creationism to q and on there is a
pattern emerging yes
and then you take cuenon and you do and
you
put them in a box of fundamentalists and
extremists and all this then
obviously automatically the other ones
that you link them to
also become part of that and people have
been removed from committees
yes because they at one time
adhere to q and on ideas
etc etc and
martin is it so that only one side
of the political divide at any given
time
is acting contrary to god's word no
or are all the kings of the world
in the same trouble when it comes to
that yes yes
is sin something that only affects one
part of the populace and not another
part of the populace
or is sin a universal problem well all
have sinned and fall short of the glory
so
so we are not taking sides we are
observers in terms of how
the pattern fits the biblical
prophecy washington times columnist
and political satirist tim young thinks
the mainstream media's obsession with q
and on has resulted in reporters and
pundits who are essentially
experts on the conspiracy so this is an
agenda that is being pushed
and maybe maybe
this kind of thinking will eventually
be attacked with such prominence
that there will be a
new direction which comes out of that
almost like happened in
the brainwashing that you had in
political systems
in the nazi world and in communism
etc yes with re-education
that's the thing it's almost as if
there's an agenda
to start pushing the thinking in a
certain direction
yes and that's exactly what hegelianism
is all about
right because remember with hegelianism
you have
thesis you have antithesis
you merge them yeah and then you have
synthesis now if you want to merge
thesis and antithesis
then anything that will not merge
has to be eliminated yes right
now what won't merge the extreme fringe
won't merge so the extreme fringe on
both sides
has to be eliminated so that there can
be
a synthesis correct i correct
i can see this can you see why are they
here and why
certain of these all right now let's
think about
god and satan
now there is a thesis and an antithesis
right
yes correct you have god's view
you have satan's view i don't even want
to call it thesis then because god
doesn't have a thesis you have
two realities you have a reality
and you have an anti-reality
correct yes the one stands for god
and the other one stands anti-god for
anti-god and depending on which side
you're on you're going to be
very fervently opposed to the other side
now in god's system in this conflict
can there be a synthesis not in god's
one no
no synthesis is possible no okay so
there can be no hegelian dialectic no
not from your side
it's either this way or that way
synthesis
in the bible is syncretism
where you merge two opposing ideologies
into a synthesis the bible would call
that
syncretism yes now
uh does god condemn
syncretism more than
he would condemn the antithesis or
the anti-reality well he condemns
truth and error mixed that synthesis
correct so the problem was
that israel in the old testament
was constantly merging two
ideologies yes and they were worshiping
baal in the name of yavi
and that was totally unacceptable to god
to god
it was worse than being
totally apostate yes and we have we have
a parallel in the new testament
i wish that you were either hot
or cold but because you are in synthesis
you are
lukewarm i will spew you
out of my mouth so this theology
of merging ideologies
is not in the order of god never has
been and never will be
and satan has almost put it
the privilege of having the
extreme side and the synthesis on his
side in other words
let's take this to its logical
conclusion
if you are totally for god
then you are a fanatic for god
if you are totally for the devil you
will put
baphomet statue up and you will make
sure
people know exactly where you stand in
terms of your worship right yes
so when you have a synthesis
mustn't that absolute be removed
then what remains lukewarm yes lukewarm
is what remains
this warms what remains and that's the
one that god doesn't want
and that will be destroyed lukewarm
has to be destroyed because there is no
worse enemy than a synthesis between
truth and error
correct does that make sense
so it's like giving you a glass of water
with a dose of arsenic or strychnine in
it
it looks like good water but it'll kill
you yes
so let's just leave it at that let's
change gears a little bit
we've now had pandemic we still
are in the middle of a pandemic we've
had lockdowns
we have a totally changed society
we have changed to
[Music]
freedom of thinking to
shipology if we
can phrase if we can coin a phrase
and what has been the result well
many people have come in line with
whatever it is they have to come in line
with they have changed
their mode of thinking and operating
and many people cannot handle it at all
and so we see something happening to
society
which is rather sad one of the things
that is happening to the world
is that there is a massive increase in
suicide rate
now i know that some publications say
there
really isn't a change in the suicide
rate
but others are adamant that there is a
change
here is an article in herald live fest
of season
locked down amongst reasons for increase
in
suicide rate an alarming rise
in suicides over the past three months
in the nelson mandela bay
has at least one expert attributing this
in part to the continued national
lockdown in conjunction with the recent
festive season that was then we're now a
few months on
here's another article
in suicide during the covet 19 pandemic
as many countries face new stay-at-home
restrictions to curb the spread of
covet-19
there are concerns that rates of suicide
may
increase or have already increased
widely reported studies modeling the
effect of the covet 19 pandemic on
suicide rates
predicted increases ranging from 1 to
percent that's amazing right
largely reflecting variation in
underlying assumptions particular
emphasis has been given to the effect of
the pandemic on children
and young people now the united states
has also seen
a rise in suicides particularly in young
people
and i was interested to see that joe
biden
in one of his very recent speeches
actually said that there was a massive
increase
in suicides in his country
does that tell us that people are
despaired yeah does that tell us that
they
have lost hope many of them
does that tell us that they don't see a
future
yes now i think it's time that we
started talking about things like that
as well
is there a future if you're a young
person
and your studies are being curtailed you
cannot go to school
it doesn't look as though things are
really very bright for you and a young
person
or a child has a
a short view of life
they they cannot necessarily
bridge that gap to see well
what could happen if and so
they live in the moment and are totally
depressed here's an article in politico
and it says one quarter of young adults
contemplated suicide during the pandemic
that's 25 percent yeah it's one in four
children
isn't that horrendous that is a massive
it's where are the days
when kids were playing outside with with
sticks and stones
and little creatures here and little
creatures there
and today their life
is totally involved in this
technological world
the disconnect between people
has become yeah
this this divide of human contact
yes even when they are together
some of them will sit next to each other
and text each other rather than speak
face to face something has happened to
society
the toll is falling heaviest on young
adults
caregivers essential workers and
minorities
federal officials and public health
experts have been warning about a
potential mental health
crisis stemming from the pandemic so
there's been little
national data so far states and federal
government have some data
showing an increase in drug overdose
deaths in the first several months of
the year
amid lockdowns economic uncertainty and
added stress
caused by the pandemic
martin my problem is
that i have a very strong
idea that it's going to get worse
and not better and what is it that
humanity needs
in order to survive this god
yes they need a better understanding of
god they need a better understanding
they need something
to look beyond what's going on what is
your anchor
yes because a lot of dreams have been
shattered where's your hope
parents that had dreams for their
children
from what they can become one day yes
now that's shattered because they can't
even go to school so
there must be something to put your
anchor to anchor you
yes but these things have been coming
for a long long
time if it weren't the pandemic they
would have found another reason to say
that
this class or that class is excluded
exactly
or this class is privileged and that
class is not privileged they would find
arguments for any of these things
and then we have bill gates who warns
that an ex-pac pandemic could be 10
times worse
now if 25 of of the youth is wanting to
commit suicide in this
way what is 10 times more than that
there's nothing left right
sometimes martin i wonder whether we
should be grateful
that we have people with such a wealth
of knowledge
like bill gates he's an expert in
the computer world he's an expert on
epidemiology
he's an expert on vaccines he's an
expert
on predicting pandemics and the future
size of the pandemics what would we do
without him
but you know martin i would like to
refer you to this book
because i believe the ultimate expert of
all things
is in this book and whether there will
be
a pandemic 10 times worse than the
present
or whether there will be political
reforms
worse than a pandemic yeah
is all written in this book it's all
written here
and therefore i would recommend to our
viewers
to perhaps just take another look
at this book and see what it has to say
so just for interest sake let's talk
about
the souls of men because this is what
it's about
this whole issue is a war
for the soul that's what it is i mean
and if you if you are on the one side
or if you are on the other side
everybody in between will regard you
as part of the lunatic fringe yes right
so what about the souls of men daniel 6
5 then said these men we shall
not find any occasion against this
daniel except we find it against him
concerning the law
of his god that's a very fascinating
statement
now daniel was a very high official he
was basically the prime minister right
yeah one position under the king under
the king
he was the executive officer okay did
they like him
no yeah his peers did not did not like
him at all
what irritated them what irritated them
about them
the law yes his absolute
rigid adherence
to the bible
so this is very fascinating
so this law of god
is a very prominent feature isn't it
we were talking about suicides
that's people that have lost hope right
did daniel ever want to commit suicide
no he became a very old man right yes
and did he from a young age i mean he
was
we saw now the sewer rates of
young people yes he was 17 years old
when he was taken
absolutely did he have a couple of rough
experiences definitely
yeah yeah thrown to the lions yes
so he had some very did his friends go
through tough times
yes but they had something
that anchored them and according to this
verse
the thing that anchored him was his
adherence to
the law of god that's the bible the
torah
including the law now
do you think god has a cause
that is of such paramount
importance that he would be prepared to
die for it
yes do you think so yes all right
and let's take political systems in the
world
communism capitalism
that's a thesis an antithesis right yep
which has to be fused into it synthesis
do you think martin that there were
people on both sides of that divide
that are so involved in that cause be it
communism or capitalism
that they would be prepared to die to
maintain it
yes and there were haven't millions and
millions of people died because they
stood for those causes
yes so what gives them this further
the absolute faith and conviction in
conviction
that their cause is right right and
anybody who doesn't accept their cause
does not have a right to exist do we
have that same kind of thinking in the
religious world
yes and are some people so
fervent for their cause that they will
be prepared to destroy
anyone who does not come into harmony
with their cause yes
okay so you already said that god has a
cause
and he will not move from his cause he
said i will not alter
what has gone out of my mouth
now if earthly governments
and earthly systems of government can be
a cause that can
empower people then surely this
cause that has been raging for thousands
of years now
is a very important cause don't you
think indefinitely
it's life and if it's life and death
and if you have chosen to align yourself
with this cause would you be
someone that says well i'll just
capitulate or
will you be prepared to get onto the
barricades put on the battle dress and
go to war
yep you'll go to war
and it's only it's not only life and
death it's eternal life and eternal
death
that is the issue and as we've already
said there's no synthesis
in this war now what is the war about
we need to understand the war
if we read here from this statement here
it says
i saw the nominal church and the nominal
adventists like judas
would portray us to the catholics to
obtain their influence to come against
the truth
the saints then will be an obscure
people little known to the catholics
remember we
discussed this statement in our previous
what's up
but the churches and the nominal
adventists who know of our faith and
customs
for they hated us on account of the
sabbath for they could not refute it
will betray the saints and report them
to the catholics
as those who disregard the institutions
of the people
that is they keep the sabbath and
disregard sunday
now we will discuss this one in quite
some detail
and we saw that you can only be
portrayed
in this sense to a power that has ruling
authority right
and that the issue will be the sabbath
now again we saw in our introduction
that the sabbath is definitely going to
be
part of all of this
in deuteronomy 24 7 there's an
interesting verse it says if a man be
found stealing any of his brethren
of the children of israel and maketh
merchandise of him
or selleth him then that thief shall die
and thou shalt put evil away from
amongst you
if you have been bought
by the blood of the lamb if the price
has been paid for you
are you merchandise yes
you've been bored who do you belong to
to god
okay is it important therefore to know
whether the one who purchased you
is a god of love or whether he is a
tyrant
it is important do you think it's
important yes because to know if you're
going to be treated like a slave
or a free man okay now
is it therefore important to study the
character of this particular deity
yes do you have a choice in the matter
yes yes does god force you
to accept him no doesn't he say that you
have to accept him by faith
yes and that he wants you to come he's
reached out his hands and say come
but people refuse right correct or some
don't refuse
it is a choice so this god
doesn't force you and he regards
anyone who makes merchandise of men
as worthy of death isaiah 45
14 says thus says the lord the labor of
egypt and the merchandise of ethiopia
and of the sabians
men of stature shall come over unto thee
and they shall be thine
they shall come after thee in chains
they shall come over and they shall fall
down unto thee they shall make
supplication unto thee saying
surely god is in thee and there is none
else there is no god humanity
in general are they in chains yes
yes they are in chains
they have been captured they have been
converted into merchandise
what was the penalty for that death
death
death and here they will come at the end
and say we want that god
surely it must be of absolute
paramount importance
that humanity must understand the
character of god
right definitely i think the biggest
problem in the world is a
misunderstanding of god's character
that is the biggest problem because how
can i accept
god if i misunderstand
his character now we spoke about
creation evolution
i spoke about the book the god delusion
where the character of god is maligned
as this
monster this genocidal monster
who says my way or the highway and will
destroy
anyone that doesn't come into harmony
now when you read the old testament
that is the picture of god that is in
the minds of people right
and taking that picture you
reject god and we have
theologians in the jesus seminar for
example
and these people say that
when you study these things you will
love the god of the new testament
but the god of the old testament you
will hate
or putting it in other words you will
love the son and hate the father
yeah but jesus said i am the father of
one
so is it important that we understand
these differences
yes definitely absolutely absolutely
does god have a system of governance
yeah yes
there is no government without law right
they've already changed law to legal but
that's a different issue
that's a totally different issue but
there is a basis for god's government
and as we read about daniel
the problem lies with the law
and we won't find anything against him
unless it has to do with the law
now if we take the ten commandments
and you read thou shalt not kill
honor thy father and thy mother thou
shalt not steal thou shalt not bring
false testimony
thou shalt not covet etc etc
but those are all laws that everybody
will say well that's a logical thing to
do
right correct and then it says remember
the sabbath day to keep it holy
in six days the lord made the heavens
that's a q a non theory isn't it
that's what they claim yes isn't that a
cure non-theory
in six days the lord made the heavens
the earth the sins
and all that is in them that's q and on
therefore he commanded you to keep the
sabbath day yeah that's that's what that
guy did he said the same that they've
got conspiracy theories
creationists are conspiracy theories sir
all right so now are you saying
excuse me but i believe that god created
me in six days
uh you're in the lunatic fringe right
immediately
but the promise is that those that are
in chains
will come the church has something to
sell too you know that
it's called the gospel and she is a
merchant
in ezekiel 27 33 we read
when thy wares went forth out of the
seas
there are phillips many people thou
didst enrich the kings of the earth with
a multitude of thy riches and of thy
merchandise
is that a beautiful verse yes so are we
talking about
literal fish from the sea here and
things like that
or are we talking about the gospel the
gospel definitely
so what are the wares that the church
has to sell the gospel of
jesus christ right and she went forth
out of the seas
that's the nations all the nations
and the people were filled and you
enriched kings of the earth with a
multitude of thy riches
and of thy merchandise there is
something to sell there is a merchandise
john 2 verse 16 says and said unto them
that
soul doves take these things hence
make not my father's house a house of
merchandise
there's a literal merchandise and
there's a spiritual merchandise
which one is acceptable to god the
spiritual one
the spiritual one when it comes to the
church i mean everybody has to buy
things
you have to live you have to have food
god is not against that
but when it comes to the message
there's a spiritual message and the
message has to do
with the character of god yeah
that is the message so
the god of the old testament and the god
of the new testament
you know it's absolutely imperative that
we understand these things
where are we going to we're going to
isaiah chapter
33 martin my bible is falling apart
again
it's most disconcerting
woe to thee that spoilers and thou was
not spoiled
and dealers treacherously and they dealt
not treacherously with thee
god is totally against unfair practices
using people when they never used you
trampling on people when they never
trampled upon you
lording over people lording it over
people
and there will be a retribution
according to that first verse
it'll come back on your own head verse 2
says oh lord be gracious unto us
we have waited for thee be thou their
arm
every morning our salvation also in the
time of trouble
people need to read their bibles to
understand
where we are in the stream of time this
is a timeless book
it's totally timeless verse 5 says the
lord is exalted for he dwelleth on high
as
filled zion with judgment and
righteousness
these are the issues that matter and
like just to go back to what you just
said if you read the bible
you can see it in today's day it's time
yes
that's why i agree it's okay everything
is in here you can
apply it right into what you see today
verse 6 says and wisdom
and knowledge shall be the stability of
thy times
and strength of salvation the fear of
the lord
is his treasure we need to understand
god and then we will have stability
even in times of turmoil and this
fear is not a scary fear no
it's not respectful it's respect for god
and if you have respect for someone
then you have
knowledge of the way in which he acts
i was one confronted once confronted by
a superior who demanded respect
and i told the gentleman concerned
that respect is earned it's not
inherited he was not very pleased with
what i had to say
but that is the case how it works
if we drop down to verse 10 it says now
will i rise says the lord now will i be
exalted
now will i lift up myself you shall
conceive
chaff ye shall bring forth stubble your
breath is as fire
shall devour you and the people shall be
as the burning of time as
thorns cut up shall they be burned in
the fire here's the god of
vengeance right don't mess with him and
this is the idea that many people have
hear ye that are far off what i have
done
and ye that are near acknowledge
my might so god is saying
acknowledge my might and then he has
this
interesting statement the sinners in
zion are afraid fearfulness has
surprised
the hypocrites he's addressing his own
people yes
okay so this is not a question of just
the outside
world versus his world no he's
addressing the sinners
who amongst us shall dwell with the
devouring fire
who amongst us shall dwell with
everlasting burnings
that's a fascinating verse you see god
is a consuming fire
and people always say you know when
you're wrong you're going to the hot
place
no when you are redeemed you go to the
hot place
you're going to live in the presence of
burning fire just
like daniel's three friends were not
consumed in the fire
so this is a very good question who will
dwell
when it comes to that time when you're
standing before the mighty god who is a
consuming fire
and then the answer comes he that
walketh righteously
speaketh uprightly he that despises the
gain
of oppressions that shaketh his hand
from holding of bribes
that stop us his ears from hearing of
blood
and shutteth his eyes from seeing evil
he shall dwell on high his place of
defense shall be
the munitions of the rocks bread shall
be given him his waters shall be sure
thine eyes shall see the king in his
beauty
they shall behold the land that is very
far
off in other words you're going to be in
the very presence of god you will see
the king in his beauty
referring to jesus christ sitting on the
throne of god
even though that seems far off is this
hope
definitely is there a condition yes
there's a condition obedience now if we
go down a little bit further
it says in verse 22
for the lord is our judge
the lord is our lawgiver
the lord is our king
he will save us okay
so he's our judge he's our law giver
and he is our king so
if he is the judge there must be a
standard of judgment
correct what is the standard of judgment
he's law the law
he's the law giver and he's the ruler
he's the king
yeah and he says to you obey
but he doesn't force you no and that's
the beauty
and then he's got a promise all right so
now it will save you
if you read it now in this context in
verse chapter 33
then you find that god is a consuming
fire
to those who go against his law
we will find nothing against him if it
has not something to do with his law
right god is a consuming fire
to those who go against his law
martin the governments of this world
are they consuming fire to those who go
against their law
yes don't you go to jail
definitely is there a possibility you
could go to the electric chair
yes are they agitating
that people must be re-educated
and when they re-educate people in some
of these
centers do they use techniques of
torture is that an acknowledged fact
yes yes unfortunately yes so the earthly
governments have a law
and the heavenly government has the law
and god says i'm the lawgiver
and i'm the judge and my standard is the
law
and i'm your king and you don't have to
choose me
but the consequence is you will be
consumed
by the consuming fire yeah if you choose
me
i will protect you against the consuming
fire and you will stand
in the consuming fire and not even the
wimp
of smoke will be upon you right
yes so he's absolutely adamant
that his law stands and he calls it
righteousness right
yes and if everybody kept the law
down to the minutest detail there would
be no confusion
and if i might add there will be no
unhappiness
no cannot be because a lot of people
will say
um yes but god now says you must be
part of keep the law or you'll be part
of the consuming fire
then the next thing you have to do is
look at the law
and see what the outcome of it is is it
for
bad or for good or is it for good so
we have to look at the basis for the
government of god
and the basis is there is
a system of rules and regulations
which determine righteousness
versus unrighteousness if everybody
kept the law out of conviction
then they would have no other gods
besides them because there is no other
god beside them yes
right there would not be idolaters
because why would you want to worship an
object
or an activity if you can worship
the real thing right yes you would have
a certain amount of respect
and you would not be blasphemous if you
knew that this being
actually created you can you see why
evolution and creation is such an
important issue
definitely can you see why
a personal god versus a
diffuse pantheistic god is a very
important issue
yes is god
a god of relationships or is god
just a diffuse essence that permeates
everything
including you making you god he's such a
personal god that he
longs for you to come and talk to him
and spend time with him
so he says come let us reason together
and then he says
okay i'll set a memorial
i'll set a memorial which says that i am
the god that created you
in six days and i want you to rest from
your regular work
and to spend time with me on that day
because i
am a personal god who wants a personal
interaction with you and i'm setting the
sabbath as a memorial
will you accept that sabbath yeah and i
want it to be a delight
that we can enjoy our time together
isaiah chapter 58
right call the sabbath a delight in the
lord's
day honorable
is that a law of a personal god or
of a pantheistic diffuse god
personal and that also is not
a bondage law it's setting you free
okay martin when you were married
did you willingly go into bondage
[Laughter]
yes you willingly went into bondage
did you put on sackcloth and ashes on
your head on the day that you went into
that bondage
no no i was celebrating you were
celebrating because you thought there
was going to be something special in
this relationship
right so let's say that that first table
in the ten commandments tells
us where we come from who we're dealing
with
and what our relationship is to be right
pretty logical and then he says okay now
having
established that let me show you what
your relationship should be amongst
yourselves
first thing that he'll tell you is you
know what
you came into this world and somebody
took care of you
and you were not exactly the most
pleasant
object
like shakespeare put it mulling and
puking in the nurse's arm
and somebody lovingly took care of you
and didn't find it a bondage
but a pleasure right therefore honor
that relationship
honor your father and your mother so
that it may be well with you
and then all the other rules and
regulations don't harm each other don't
somebody's worked hard for his stuff
don't go and take it
leave it alone lie to him don't do this
don't go and covet it
it's very logical and then god says
that's what i stand for and i will not
compromise what has gone out of my mouth
and i will not change it
is somebody the right to go and change
it and peddle that off as
merchandise has somebody
the right to kidnap you
into any one of their systems
and say you're no longer bound to that
system you're now bound to my system
that's robbery correct what is the
penalty
death death let's continue
so there are kinds of merchandise which
the church sells
there is also merchandise that political
systems sell
now we know that god has a political
system
and he he doesn't want to force you
but he asks you to accept it now lucifer
is a merchant too it says in ezekiel 28
by the multitude of thy merchandise
they have filled the midst of thee with
violence
and there has sinned therefore i will
cast thee as a profane
out of the mountain of god and i will
destroy thee o covering cherub
from the midst of the stones of fire
i will remove you there's no synthesis
with this merchant what is his
merchandise
any product of sin anything that is
against god's law
thou shalt not commit adultery
does he peddle the merchandise of
adultery
yes very definitely does he
remember the sabbath to keep it holy
does he
peddle a counterfeit sabbath and
sells it off to you as the real thing
when it is counterfeit and
everything that he sells to you looks so
much
more easy
yes it looks so like that's more of a
delight
correct so when the commandments talk
about
father and mother is that gender
specific
yes so when you make rules
that that specificity no longer exists
and that you know the privacy of people
will no longer be respected in that
regard
are you peddling a kind of merchandise
in the world
yup okay ii peter 2
3 says and through covetousness shall
they
with feigned words
make merchandise of you whose judgment
now of a long time lingereth not
and their damnation slumbereth not
by captivating you with fancy words and
ideologies
are they making merchandise of you
you're a commodity you're a commodity
revelation 18 11 says and the merchants
of the earth shall weep and mourn over
her for no man buys their merchandise
anymore
this is merchandise not only in the
physical sense but also in the spiritual
sense
there's so much merchandise out there
that is not
in harmony with god's word so basically
what i'm saying here is if you don't
have a cause
then there's nothing to live for
you will bear hardship you will
suffer probation you will go through
cold you will go through hunger
you will do anything if your cause
is strong enough correct and therefore
nobody would commit suicide
if they had a cause that was stronger
than the desire
for suicide revelation 18 verse 12 the
merchandise of gold and
silver and precious stones and of pearls
and fine linen and purple and silk and
scarlet
of all thine wood and all manner of
vessels of ivory and all manner of
vessels of
precious wood and of brass and of iron
and of
marble and cinnamon and odours and
ointments and frankincense and wine and
oil
and flower and wheat and beasts and
sheep and horses and chariots and
slaves and the souls of men
now many of those items are the
religious nature
the scarlet the color yes that is used
in the religious sense the precious
stones the pearls the fine linen
all of these things the cinnamon the
odors the ointments the frankincense
if you go to some of these churches all
of these
are part of creating
a spiritual milieu and selling a
merchandise
contrary to god's word yeah and then
making slaves of men
and selling the souls of men
that happens in this world in a literal
sense
and that happens in a spiritual sense
now the q anon theory
had much to do with slavery
and abuse gender abuse
etc you know what martin that takes
place in the world no matter what
political party you belong to
yeah it seems it takes place no matter
what religious affiliation you have
the news is full of it you cannot
categorize
sin into a political system
sin is sin it's not a political party
and any political party
take note any political party
any system of government that
incorporates aspects of sin
as morally justified
is in a state of synthesis correct
so you could have an absolute
conservative government
with absolute conservative religious
attributes
and they could have religious dogmas
like sunday
keeping which is a merchandise
contrary to god's law incorporated
in their system yes and they would be
synthesis
so you've got all this morally perfect
and even the sunday it seems morally
perfect
but it's defined contrary to what god
said
and you can have an ultra liberal
government
with anything goes
where you can make laws where men and
women can decide what gender
they are and compete with each other on
the sport field
irrespective of the physical differences
and it becomes so ridiculous that you do
not even
know where you are standing
that is synthesis still on the same page
same page just different standards
different norms different laws
incorporated into a system
that is being sold as merchandise
the right thing to do yeah
for the common good yeah we said that at
the same time
so the question i have here
are we merchandise to satan and is there
a tendency by our enemies to
sell us to him yes
is there a tendency to sell ourselves
that's an important question right i
think unfortunately the answer is yes
we all have a tendency to sell ourselves
because we have a sinful nature what are
the motives for such a transaction
why would you sell yourself fear
hatred whoredom
want of recognition these are all
driving forces to embed you
in his system let's take fear for
example
in the bible pharaoh takes sarah
abraham's wife and here you have these
amazing words by abram himself
say i prayed either or my sister that it
may be well with
me for thy sake and my soul shall live
because of thee
he's afraid that he will die and he's
prepared
to sell his wife in a sense
yeah to pharaoh now what does pharaoh
stand for
governments governments okay
uh what does the woman the wife stand
for
church church so
is it possible that people are willing
to sell their
church for fear of pharaoh yes
does pharaoh covet the church to be on
his side
yes if pharaoh
was an ultra conservative then he would
like the ultra-conservative churches to
be on board
with his thinking and with their
syncretism
yes if pharaoh is an ultra liberal
then he would want this ultra liberal
church to be on his side and say
you know what the bible is very outdated
we have to move with the times
correct correct yeah they came to pass
that when abraham was in egypt the
egyptians beheld the woman that she was
very
fair and the princes also pharaoh saw
her and commended her before pharaoh and
the woman was taken into pharaoh's house
you know we must be very careful that
the woman isn't taken into pharaoh's
heart
would you agree when church and state
come together
it's a problem correct and it's an
unlawful
marriage it's unlawful
and he entreated abraham well for her
sake
and he had sheep and oxen and asses and
manservants and maidservants and she
asses and camels
was he paid yes
merchandise is it possible that the
church can become
merchandise in this conflict
i think it's inevitable it's inevitable
and then it does it again abba malek
takes sarah
and abraham journeyed from thence
towards the south country and dwelt
between kardesh and sur
and sergeant ingerah and abraham said to
sarah's wife she's my sister
and abele melech king of gerar sent and
took sarah
same thing i think there's a tendency
to sell the church to pharaoh
is it lawful no is it legal
they perceive it to be they perceive it
to be
and again abimelech took sheep and oxen
and manservants and woman servants and
gave them to abraham
was it a transaction yes it was paid
again
it's a transaction it's a merchandise
now isaac didn't fall far from the tree
he had the same tendencies it seems that
the next generation doesn't learn
from the mistakes right no so
isaac and abimelech and isaac dwelled in
guerra
and the men of the place asked him of
his wife and he said
she is my sister.
terrible isn't that terrible well
actually he wasn't lying because they
were all half yeah
yeah well you know that's telling you of
truth now why did he say that and it
tells us there
he feared to say he feared to say she is
my wife
lest he said he the man of the place
should kill me for rebecca because she
was
fair to look upon and it came to pass
when he had been there a long
time so this is a terrible situation
yeah
do we have this today do we have
situations where we are
the there was a certain way of saying
things
and now uh to be a little bit more
politically correct we
now she's my sister she's my sister that
abimelech king of the philistines looked
out at the window and saw
and behold isaac was spotting with
rebecca his wife
he was cuddling her so he knew there was
something wrong here right
now who's the real husband in this
church situation
jesus jesus who covets her
pharaoh or abimelech right king of
guerra
the governments of the world will want
the church in the bag
when the church is in the bag it is
committing adultery
against its husband
and in order to get her in the bag he
has to compromise the law he has to
consider her as merchandise
and if you sold someone then the penalty
was what martin
death that interesting
death abimelech called isaac and said
behold of
surety she is thy wife and how said thou
she is my
sister why would he say that fear
he was willing to compromise
his very relationship
out of fear do you think many will
follow that path
unfortunately yes i think so because i
said lest i die for her
we mustn't forget that the only way that
we will be able to maybe stand
is with god absolutely not be
not fearful on your own if abraham and
isaac had internalized that concept
they would have known that god will take
care of it because god had made many
promises that hadn't been fulfilled yet
so we should not submit
to fear in order to compromise our faith
correct again isaac didn't have to give
up his way
wife she wasn't taken up by any of the
others
but again he had flocks and possessions
and herds and servants
and the philistines envied him if you
are faithful to god there will be envy
there will be endings like the same
thing in daniel
correct and then you have the great type
the story of joseph in the bible
and here the motive was hatred
do you think hatred could be a motive in
the time that we are living in
yeah we see hatred a lot in the world
today
do you think people would be willing to
sell
whole people because of hatred
so he exposed the sins of his brothers
and he had something which set him apart
he had the spirit of prophecy joseph
he had the prophetic gift and the
prophetic gift
irked his brethren yeah
they hated him because he was upright
and pointed out their sins
and because of his visions he
had the gift of prophecy and they hated
him because of it let's read
genesis 37 verse 2 these are the
generations of
jacob joseph being 17 years old
it's amazing how often this comes up
right
daniel was 17. mary was probably
17. he was feeding the flock with his
brethren and the lad
was with the sons of bilhah and with the
sons of
zilpah his father's wives
and joseph brought unto his father
their evil report
now the sons of bilhah were dan and
naphtali
and the sons of zilpah were gad
and asha so dan and naphtali and gad
and asha were not very happy
with joseph he brought their evil report
so let's let's make this spiritual
so if there is a church that says
excuse me there is an evil report
about that church that church
that church and that church
will they be very charmed no
would they perhaps be willing to sell
you as a slave
correct okay give you up
give you up so this is what happened
then joseph went and visited these
brothers in the field
and they said and when they saw him a
far
off even before he came near unto them
they conspired against him to slay him
do you think that could happen in our
days conspiracy theorists
and they said one to another behold this
dreamer
cometh they hate the spirit of prophecy
they cannot stand exactly why should
these
people have these visions which
basically
condemn what we do right
come now therefore and let us slay him
and cast him into some pit and we will
say some evil beast has devoured him and
we shall see what will become of his
dreams
didn't they link the seventh-day
adventist church to
failed cue and non-visions correct
so aren't they saying that this church
is a dreamer
and what do they want to do with the
dreamer
to put it over to the evil beasts yes
did they think that
his visions and dreams were false
prophecies
yes were they false prophecies no
they were pointing out their sins only
time could tell right yes
we will see what becomes of his false
vision
so they sold them now it's interesting
and judah said unto his brethren what
prophet
is it if we slay our brother and conceal
his blood
come let us sell him to the ishmaelites
and let not our hand be upon him for is
our brother and our flesh
and his brethren were content did they
make merchandise of him
yes then they passed by
midianites merchant men this is a
recurring theme in the bible isn't it
yeah
and they drew and lifted up joseph out
of the pit and they sold
joseph to the ishmaelites for 20
pieces of silver and they brought joseph
into egypt
the merchants in revelation
that hands over their power they also
will be handing over merchandise
absolutely and does people form part of
that merchandise
absolutely they are dealing in the souls
of men
and then the mediamites sold him in
egypt unto potiphar
an officer of pharaohs and captain of
the god
so they bought him for 20 pieces of
silver
being merchant men do you think they
wanted to make a profit
i'm sure they did now would 33
sound like a good profit yes so could
you
guess it doesn't say so that they might
have sold him for 30 pieces of silver
might sound good was somebody else sold
for 30 pieces of silver
yes well i am i am speculating
i'm not being a conspiracy theorist
so my question is was jesus sold
for 30 pieces of silver so they
the world is even willing to sell
the creator yeah isn't that amazing
zachariah this beautiful prophecy says
and i said
unto them if you think good give me my
price and if not for bear
so they wait for my price 30 pieces of
silver
joseph the type was sold
maybe for 30 pieces of silver
he was bought for 20 and here jesus
is sold for 30 pieces of silver
verse 13 says and the lord said unto me
cast it unto the potter a goodly price
that i was prized out of them
and i took 30 pieces of silver and cast
them to the potter in the house of the
lord and in matthew we know and i said
unto them who will give me
and i will deliver him unto you and they
covet it with him for thirty pieces of
silver so here
is a fulfillment of prophecy
what happens to those who make
merchandise of god's people
death death
jesus paid that price he paid that price
then judas which had betrayed him when
he saw that he was condemned repented
himself and brought again the 30 pieces
of silver to the chief priests and the
elders
then was fulfilled that which was spoken
by jeremy the prophet
saying and they took the thirty pieces
of silver the peace of him that was
valued whom they of the children of
israel
did value this tendency to make
merchandise of men
has existed from the very beginning
and if you realize that you are not
merchandise
then life has value
and when you realize that god doesn't
coerce you to keep the law
but invites you to keep the law based on
principle then you have
something to stand for yes you have
something to stand for
though the heavens fall around you you
have become a
soldier for a cause
and just as a communist or a fascist
or a whatever is can have a cause
so you have a cause yes which is a
righteous cause
and then you will also not feel that the
law of god
is a yoke no it's not a yoke it's a
principle
and then you'll also understand that
when they say in romans
that you're not under the condemnation
of the law it doesn't mean
not keeping the law anymore it means
that this
this the transgression of the law
which means death you're not condemned
anymore with under that
because you set free with the law
absolutely
if you take the story of joseph
there were seven fat years
symbolized by the kind and by the corn
and then there were seven linears and
the seven linears
consumed the seven factors
and by the end of that those seven years
all the egyptians had been dispossessed
of everything that they own yes
do you think that could serve as a type
for the times we are living in
do you think pharaoh will own
everything and
isn't that what the world economic forum
says yes you will own
nothing and you'll be happy you've said
that now
three or four times yeah but it is the
truth every time you say it that is what
they said
so do you think it's possible that in
that story
there is a present reality
that is encapsulated in that story
i believe so i think it is a distinct
possibility now the israelites
themselves
they came as free men
but then they were enslaved
isaiah and his wife is another example
in the bible
the beginning of the word of the lord by
hosea this is
isaiah chapter 1 and the lord said to
isaiah go
take unto thee a wife of whoredoms and
children of whoredoms
for the land has committed great
whoredom departing
from the lord so here we have another
example
one of the questions i asked is are we
willing
to enslave so fear was a motivator right
fear was a motivator like jealousy and
hatred was a motivator
and now whoredom is a motivator
for the land has committed great
whoredom departing from the lord so this
was an
object lesson so he went and took gomer
the daughter of
diblaim which conceived and bare him as
son
and she was constantly unfaithful to him
so it's a sad reality
that churches today are willing
of their own accord
to give up their allegiance to
their true husband correct and go
into these alignments such as the
economical movement
and gomer then eventually when you do
that out of your own free will
you end up being merchandise and said
the lord unto me go
yet love a woman beloved of a friend
yet an adulteress according to the love
of the lord towards the
children of israel there's the parallel
who look to other gods and love flagons
of wine false doctrine
so i bought her to me for 15
pieces of silver and for a homer of
barley and a half a homer
of barley so one and a half homers of
bali
so when you sell yourself
out of your own free will for the sake
of whoredom
you become a slave yeah
and he bought her back and it's
interesting that he brought it back
for with silver and he brought her back
with barley now barley is a symbol of
the
early harvest
and i think god is harvesting his people
he wants to buy back
the people that have enslaved themselves
through whoredom it's time for the
church to wake up
it's time for all the churches it's time
for
all the religious systems of the world
to wake up if you are
in pharaoh's house if you
are enslaved by the king of babylon
time to come out
so the problem what was the problem
the problem firstly was isaiah 4
6 my people are destroyed for lack of
knowledge
because thou hast rejected knowledge i
will also reject thee
that thou shalt be no priest to me
seeing thou hast forgotten what
the law you have forgotten the law of
god
every time when you study the issue of
slavery
in the bible it has to do with
transgression of god's law
yes is there a law which says thou shalt
not commit adultery
not steal
correct is there a law which says thou
shalt not covet
is there a law which says there's only
one god and you must worship him
is there law where he says i have a day
whereby you acknowledge that i am your
creator and your redeemer
and every time when that those laws were
transgressed
israel had problems they had problems
and every time you have a synthesis
between two systems then you become
a prostitute and you become
a fallen prostitute right
okay so what was the problem they forgot
the law of god
and so god said i will forget you
so how do we come back into harmony with
god
we have to keep the law go back to the
law why because you're afraid of god
no because you love him because you love
him and because the principle is fair
his principle has become your principle
therefore you're no longer a slave but a
brother
yeah that's the principle
and then he warns and he says therefore
i viewed them by the prophets
he gave them the prophets i have slain
them by the words of my mouth and thy
judgments are as the light that goes
forth
for i desired mercy and not sacrifice
and the knowledge of god more than burnt
offerings but they like men have
transgressed the covenant
they have dealt treacherously against me
it's not rocket science
it's not difficult so the only other
thing that is open to them
is to say let's reject the entire bible
as a myth
then none of these issues apply
or let's take the first six days
that's not of nonsense and then you've
got that syncretism again
full of nonsense but it also got truth
doesn't help
isaiah 7 8 ephraim he has mixed himself
amongst the people that was the next
problem
ephraim is a cake not turned
beautiful description yeah you have to
be
fully bagged in other words he's
half-packed
half-baked what is half-baked lukewarm
lukewarm
he's neither hot nor cold he's
half-baked
that's the problem exactly
strangers have devoured his strength and
he knoweth it not
ye gray hairs are here and there upon
him yet he knoweth not
and the pride of israel testifieth
to his face there's the other problem
right
so pride being
lukewarm and you know at night and they
did not return to the lord their god nor
seek him for all of this ephraim also
is like a silly dove without heart
they call to egypt and they go to
assyria
can pride be linked to tradition
absolutely
absolutely but look look what she is
she's a silly dove
now a dove is a clean animal right it
was even a sacrificial animal
and she has a tendency to go to egypt
now when you want to accept evolution
rather than what the word of god says
you're actually in egypt right but they
also go to assyria
assyria is the symbol of babylon yeah
false gods
false religion false god anything but
the truth
i'll either believe nothing or i'll
believe
syncretism
when israel was a child then i loved him
and called my son out of egypt what a
beautiful prophecy about jesus right
as they called them so they went from
them they sacrificed unto balaam they
burnt
insane to graven images i taught ephraim
also to go taking them by their arms
but they knew not that i healed them
i drew them with cords of a man with
bands of love and i was to them
as they that take off the yoke on their
jaws
and i laid meat unto them i gave them
food i gave them good food
he shall not return into the land of
egypt but the assyrian shall be his king
because they refuse to return they come
out of egypt and they end up in assyria
isn't that ridiculous now this god of
the old testament martin
a god of love or a god of terror well
from all we've
just read i can't see any terror i see
the love
so when uh
evolutionary friends like dawkins
tell us that the god of the old
testament
is miserable and the god of the new
is a spineless softie
that's what he does yeah it's crazy
that's what he says
does he have a concept of god does he
understand
judgment righteousness
mercy justice law
does he understand any of these issues
and the sword shall abide on his cities
and shall consume his branches and
devour them
because of their councils
god gets the blame for everything
but when things go wrong they are
themselves to blame
and my people are bent to backsliding
from me
though they called them to the most high
none at
all would exalt him
ephraim feedeth on wind and followeth
after the east wind
all kinds of religious
ideologies anything is acceptable
you can mix yoga meditation
eastern meditation with biblical
meditation
anything goes your daily increases
lies and desolation and they do make a
covenant with the assyrians and
oil is carried into egypt
merchandise with a false
gospel yet i
am the lord thy god from the land of
egypt and thou shalt know no god but
me for there is no savior beside me o
israel thou has destroyed thyself
but in me is thine help i will be thy
king
where is any other that may save thee in
all thy cities and thy judges of whom
thou says give me a king and princes
i gave thee a king in my anger and took
him away in my wrath
we have all this history and
we are bent on repeating the mistakes
we need a cause and our
weapons are not carnal our weapons
are the sword of the spirit which is the
word of god
and we need to infuse humanity with this
ideology that gives you a
firm foundation which gives you hope
and a future
so let's say that god permitted this
great evil to expose
the great iniquity allowed his people
israel to be handed over to the
assyrians
he allowed his people judah to be handed
over to babylon
he allowed his anti-typical people to be
handed over to
antitypical babylon but he does not want
them to stay there
he wants them to learn something
when they realize that they have been
enslaved he wants to bring them
out of there with a mighty hand and an
outstretched arm and he says flee
from babylon don't lust after the
fleshpots of
egypt don't say numbers 14 verse 2 and
all the children of israel
murmured against moses and against aaron
and a whole congregation
and said unto them would god that we had
died in the land of egypt or would god
we have died in the wilderness because
it could just happen
come out come out of my people.
would you agree martin that the question
who do you belong to
is an important question in terms of
the way we should conduct ourselves and
the times that we are yes i think it's
the most important question
of your life the most important question
is who do you belong to
yes that's definitely because that
that is where it separates yes when i
was an atheist i didn't know who i
belonged to yes
right so this is the most important
question who do you belong to
isaiah 43 verse 1 but now thus says the
lord
that created thee o jacob and he that
formed thee o
israel fear not for i have redeemed thee
i've called thee by thy name thou art
mine
here you have creation plus you have
redemption and you have
this call don't be afraid it doesn't
matter what happens around you
you are in the palm of his
hand and if you believe that with all
your heart
no matter what weapon they forge against
you
it does not matter
1 corinthians 6 20 for you are bought
with a price
therefore glorify god in your body and
in your spirit which are god's what is
the price that was paid for you
the blood of this yes everything he died
for you
everything you're bought with a price
1 corinthians 7 23 be
not ye the servants of men
if you are bought then you have become
merchandise
but you have been bought with a price by
god
there are two that's dealing in
merchandise
god and satan and you have to decide
to whom you are sold to and then it's
pivotal that you understand the
character
and if you confuse the old testament
with the new testament god
then you are in trouble when you see
that the issue is a
ideology a cause
worthy of standing for when you embrace
that cause
then you have found life and then you
will not be bought
one peter 1 verse 18 for as much as you
know that you are
not redeemed with corruptible things as
silver and gold from your vain
conversation received by tradition from
your fathers
but with the precious blood of christ as
of a lamb without
blemish and without spot who verily was
foreordained before the foundation of
the world
but was manifest in these last times
for you i think i want to end there
and just re-emphasize
the point in the times that we are
living
we need a cause a
cause which will enable us to endure
whatever yes the world has to throw at
us
if like we've heard if there's a
possibility of another pandemic
ten times worse if it's whatever comes
to
your on your way absolutely we have to
have that cause
we have to have the cause we must have
faith
in the prophesied outcome of the
conflict
so that we do not stare at the
difficulties
but look beyond them to the
glorious heritage of the children of god
yes so let us stand together without
fear and trembling and let us stand
like daniel stood we will find
nothing against him except it has to do
with
his law of his god
and you might get thrown into the lion's
den
but remember what happened to him you
might be thrown
into the fiery furnace but remember what
happened to them
you might be sold as a slave like
joseph was but remember what happened to
him
these are the things that give us hope
and give us a reason to live and give us
the courage and the endurance that we
need
for the times that we are living in will
you pray for us martin i will
our heavenly father without you we can
do nothing
and without you we don't want to do
anything so please
help us help us to live our lives
fully dedicated to you
bless the viewers and bring us together
again
and help us in the times ahead in jesus
name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you